[موسيقى]
في اخرى ناس انفتح رؤؤسهم بكسم عنا اولاد
صغار اشبال اولاد صغار في ع سنين و 12 سنه
قاعدين
بنضربه قاعدين بتعامل باقوى
عنف
[موسيقى]
فاتوا علينا قمعه ب 30 30 عش طبش ناس كثير
في ناس بتموت بالب ايديهم تم منعي يعني من
الادويه وصار علي صعوبات كثير يعني من
ناحيه الاص في حاله الاعتقال في دخول
الجن اثر من مرحله
مر وين كنت مصاب ليش كنت مصاب في
الراس واخذوني اثناء تلقي فتره علاج
[موسيقى]
يعني وكيف وضع الاسيرات في السجون كثير
صعب كثير صعب وضيق عليهم كثير بمنعهم
يطلعوا فور فيش نفس فش اكل الاكل اللي
بالعشره بيب بجيبو يوزعو على 80 بنت
فوضعنا جدا مزري والبنات اللي بمرض وفي
بنات كثير يعني اغمى عليهم لان الضغط نزل
والسكري نزل طلعوه على وبس الدكتوره بتقول
لهم اشربوا مي هذا هو الواء وهذا هو
بالزياده علينا
بر
l